-♪ She is the queen
of the moment ♪
♪ She is the queen
of the night ♪
♪ And she brought the heavens
and brought the light ♪
♪ She's the queen
of the universe ♪
♪ Queen of the universe ♪
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Graham Norton.
That was a clip
from "Queen of the Universe."
Now, these are --
these are drag queens
on this show with great talent,
like, not just talent
as drag sort of connoisseurs,
but also, like, great,
really wonderful singers.
-If you watch "Drag Race"
and you think,
"Mm, I like it,
but why the lip-synching?"
then this is the show for you.
Because they sing,
and not just --
I mean, some of them
are incredible.
are opera singers,
and, you know,
some of them not so much,
but it's a competition.
-Yeah.
-You know, we need --
we need some cannon fodder.
So...
[ Laughter ]
But by the end,
they're all very good.
-Yeah, yeah,
and it's a little fun
to watch the cannon fodder
early on.
-It is great fun,
and it's one of those shows,
it's just joy.
It is such a fun show.
It's such a fun show
to be part of.
And, you know,
it's got the panel.
Mel B, Vanessa Williams,
Michelle Visage is on it,
Trixie Mattel,
so it's a really fun panel.
-And you -- So, RuPaul is
someone you met a long time ago.
Did you meet here in New York?
-We met in New York.
I think I saw a picture.
There's a -- I think I met him
at a Wigstock
a thousand years ago.
We have a photo, and it turns
out Ru is taller than you.
-Ru is definitely
taller than me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now, I'm --
I'm not a doctor,
but I think one of us
is aging better than the other.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's leave that
to the doctors, Graham.
-Unchanged.
Untouched by time.
Meanwhile -- Jesus.
-It's like you guys
made a deal where you're like,
"I'll take the years
for both of us."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it's my gift to drag.
-But did you do some drag
early on in your career?
-Oh, well, my --
This is weird.
The first thing I ever did --
There's a big, long story
behind it.
But the first thing
I ever did in comedy
was a one-person show
called "Mother Teresa of
Calcutta's Grand Farewell Tour."
And I played --
I played Mother Teresa
draped in Irish linen
tea towels.
And she spoke
with an Irish accent,
which, weirdly, is true,
because she learned her English
from some nuns in Dublin.
-Oh, my goodness.
-I know.
Fun fact.
Write that down.
You won't remember it
in the morning.
And that was my first thing.
So it wasn't really drag.
-Yeah, it didn't seem
like you were putting the
full effort into it.
-No, I really, really wasn't.
Yeah.
-Do you like --
Have you met over the years,
any drag names come across?
Any drag names you like
more than others?
-I mean, the drag names I like
are just the rude ones.
-The really offensive.
-I mean really terrible.
I mean really offensive.
This may be beeped, but...
So there was one
drag queen I met,
and everyone
just called her Anna.
Anna -- This is
the drag queen Anna.
And then when she went onstage,
they introduced her with
her full name, Ann Abortion.
[ Laughter ]
Oddly --
Oddly, in Tennessee,
she's now banned twice.
-Yeah, she can't do it.
I think it's like two negatives.
It makes a positive.
-Yeah. She's back.
-She's actually thriving, yeah.
That's a really --
That's a good one.
-I mean, another --
I mean, I like the way
that drag queens
don't think things through.
-Yeah.
-So they just know there's got
to be a woman's name in it
and then a funny play
on words in the second bit.
So da-da-da.
So there was a drag queen
in New York
who thought it was a good idea
to call themselves Holly Caust.
-Oh, boy.
-And then someone
explained to her --
'cause she was going,
"I don't get many gigs.
I'm not working as much
as I thought I would."
And they go,
"Do you think it's the name?
Do you think it's the name?"
And she went, "Oh, okay."
And just changed it
to Holly Days.
-And there you go.
-There you go.
-And now bounced right back.
-Yeah. Working all the time now.
Yeah.
-You're also doing Eurovision.
I feel like this is --
[ Audience cheering ]
There we go. Some.
I'm glad.
Definitely getting
a foothold here.
-This year, it's in the U.K.
-Okay.
-It hasn't been
in the U.K. for 25 years.
I mean, we didn't win
or anything, but we've got it.
-Yeah.
-And so the excitement
in Britain is fever pitch.
King Charles and --
Is she Queen Camilla?
I don't know what she is.
Anyway, they were
in Liverpool yesterday
to sort of launch
the whole thing,
and when I leave here,
I'm going back to Liverpool
'cause I'm hosting the thing,
yeah.
-And do you watch -- do you
sort of watch from onstage?
Where are you
during the performance?
-So normally,
I'm way up in the rafters.
You know,
and I can say whatever I like
because I'm never going to
meet these people.
-Sure, of course.
-This year I'm half that person,
but I'm also onstage.
-Oh, I see.
-So I will be backstage
bumping into these acts.
-Yeah.
-And you know someone rings them
the minute I say something
horrible about them.
Someone's watching going --
-Oh, I see. Right.
So you can't
go up in the rafters
and think it won't
find its way back down.
-It'll find its way
back to them, yeah.
So this year I have to be
a bit more careful.
And also, I can't laugh at the
terrible production this year
because we're doing it.
-Yeah, there you go.
Oh, right,
'cause it's usually --
-Yeah, normally you got to go,
"These hosts are terrible."
And then it's me.
Yeah.
-Well, let me tell you,
as hosts go,
I look up to you a great deal.
What a thrill to have
you here in person.
-Well, I'm thrilled to be here.
Lovely.
Thank you so much. Take care.
-Graham Norton.
Second season
of "Queen of the Universe"
will premiere on June 2nd
on Paramount+.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."